und darüber kann ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen sprechen mit eike christian
hornig parteien und demokratieforscher
liechtenstein-institut
schön dass sie da sind welche rolle
spielt für sie ihrer meinung nach so ein
tri l gestern bei den parteien und
vielleicht bei den wählerinnen wählern
aber ich glaube bei den wählerinnen
bildern spielt das schöne rolle ist mir
auch viele menschen gesehen und das ist
halt eine möglichkeit die kandidatinnen
kandidaten noch besser kennenzulernen
auch die programme noch mal zu sehen
auch mal zu sehen reagieren die unter
stress so wie verhalten die sich
eigentlich gibt es fair play was sind
inhaltliche punkte also wer sich das zu
sagen die ganze zeit an gesehen hat der
hat eine intensiv kur politischer
inhalte und personen bekommen das ist
glaube ich schon relativ wichtig für die
parteien es ist auch sehr wichtig weil
sie sich natürlich besonders gut
darstellen wollen klar wenn man die
parteien hinterfragt haben alle gewonnen
das ist immer so aber ich glaube
zwischen den zeilen kann man dann doch
schon sachen lesen und wir haben ja auch
gesehen dass man das schild
beispielsweise die reagieren ja auch
darauf wie sie im ersten teil sich
verhalten haben versuchen bestimmte
rollen zu spielen also ich glaube das
ist schon eine wichtige veranstaltung
gewesen gestern schauen wir zunächst
einmal auf armin laschet ist schon viel
gesprochen worden kämpferisch ist er
aufgetreten ist
hat angegriffen tatsächlich
wen kann armin laschet damit überzeugen
also wenn man jetzt sich die frage
stellt seine eigenen parteimitglieder
die er noch überzeugen muss ihnen zu
wählen oder tatsächlich unentschlossen
also erstmal sagen laschet ist ja
eigentlich ein ganz anderer typ also ist
eigentlich nicht der typ der so
angreifer ist und er so ein versöhner
kompromiss alle zusammen und jetzt hat
eine andere rolle die er sozusagen
spielen muss weil er eben in den
umfragen ins hintertreffen geraten ist
und ich glaube es ist tatsächlich ein
enormer druck der auf ihm lastet und
mein gefühl sagt mir dass auch bei der
eigenen klientel so zu sagen wer
innerhalb der cdu es also doch eher eine
gewisse müdigkeit gibt oder eine
ermattung nicht sozusagen mit voller
kraft in den wahlkampf zu gehen erst war
das ganze theater mit söder laschet wir
nehmen die jetzt eigentlich der ist ein
teil der cdu jetzt auch nicht ganz
zufrieden die csu gut die haben jetzt
ihren frieden gemacht also ich glaube er
hat echt schwer in der eigenen klientel
an sozusagen richtig zu mobilisieren und
das merken natürlich auch die anderen
wählerinnen und wähler dass das nicht so
ganz fahrt aufnimmt also erst den ganzen
wahlkampf noch nicht in tritt gekommen
hat er durch die angriffe gestern gegen
olaf scholz eigentlich vielleicht sogar
olaf scholz geholfen weil man ich weiß
nicht mehr genau was die formulierung
war bei anne will er hat richtig
lebendig gewirkt also olaf scholz hat er
ihnen den gefallen getan ich glaube
nicht weil olaf scholz doch aus meiner
beobachtung eher unter druck war also er
musste sich sehr rechtfertigen was eine
gute sache ist weil jemand der ein hohes
staatsamt hat dann muss sich auch
rechtfertigen das ist sozusagen auch der
sinn natürlich so einer wahl das ist im
personen sich hinstellen sagen wir haben
das gemacht und wir müssen uns
öffentlich dafür rechtfertigen das war
von der sache ja erst mal wurde ich
glaube aber so olaf scholz waren das
schwierige 20 minuten und das reihte
sich aneinander und verlassen war das
ein sicherer punkt den er vorher schon
mal ausspielen konnte deswegen geholfen
hat er ihm damit glaube ich nicht ist
wir haben alle keine glaskugel aber ist
aus ihrer sicht platz eins noch offen so
wie die union heute sagt also ich freue
mich zunehmend dagegen sozusagen jetzt
diese ganze in umfragen flut immer für
bare münze zu nehmen also alle zwei
stunden kommt ja eine neue wenn man
ehrlich ist wir haben schon erhebliche
veränderungen gesehen ich glaube die
haupt veränderung ist schon gewesen
tatsächlich dass die spd einer union
vorbeigezogen ist das glaube ich schon
aber sozusagen wie das am ende jetzt
noch wird ob die grund grünen
tatsächlich dann auch unter 20 prozent
sind dass wir das mag ich natürlich auch
nicht zu sagen einsatz noch zur
kanzlerkandidatin der grünen da hat es
geheißen gestern so in der analyse man
merkt ihr an dass sie jetzt auf platz
spielt und nicht mehr auf sieg spielt
wird er das für sie auch so das fand ich
eigentlich nicht also ich fand es waren
wieder stellen wo man auch sah wie
schlagfertig sie ist also sie hat
situation extrem gut aufgenommen und
manche sachen auch schnell gedreht also
ich fand nicht dass sie jetzt den gang
rausgenommen hat sondern sie hat ihre
punkte die sie diese gebracht hat aber
dass sie jetzt sozusagen den beiden
herren das feld überlässt das war
eigentlich nicht mal eine alterung echt
zu sein eike christian horn nicht ganz
herzlichen dank für diese einordnung
lange schön